hi I'm Ian Bremmer president of Eurasia
Group here at the World Economic Forum
in Davos I think 2008 is a year when the
United States is going to be
increasingly challenged in terms of the
insecurities that its people feel about
to what extent the trajectory that the
world is heading is one that's
beneficial for the United States so I
think there's one thing that the world
can do together it is both to help
Americans understand the globalization
and support and globalization a
leadership role in globalization is
something that continues to be important
for the world and also the world that
other states emerging markets need to
cooperate constructively with the United
States in that fashion I think never in
the course of a globalized world has the
direction of leadership in so challenged
as in 2008 the confluence of the
economic challenges that are presently
being faced with Beijing Olympics and
with an American presidential election
coming in November is unfortunate many
ways and challenges a lot of the values
that are shared by the members here of
the world economic forum in davos I
think those values need to be spoken
loudly and particularly this year so I
think if there's anything that folks in
the world can do it's to support that
thank you very much